hey David with climate change set to
transform the landscape of the globe is
there any place you want to visit before
it's gone for good
plus when sea levels do rise where do
you think you'll move a lot of the
places I want to visit our coastal right
Japan is an island nation I really want
to go to Japan there's a lot of other
places in Asia that are that are coastal
places that I want to visit but the the
second part I mean I want to go
everywhere and a lot of those places are
on the coasts I don't I don't know which
would be first I want to go to Cuba soon
before it becomes completely overrun by
Starbucks and McDonald's or whatever
else and they they have a lot of
coastline but I've actually been
thinking more and more about when sea
levels rise where will I move to because
as an elite coastal liberal Pat as you
know me to be the only places that I
could see myself living in the United
States are all coastal if you take out
the United States and say where would I
go if I went to Europe it's basically
all coastal cities I guess Brussels
isn't but it's on a river if I recall
correctly so I don't know where I'm
going to go and I'm already thinking
about that in in Boston I mean it's it's
a coastal city New York City it's a
coastal city I love Miami and San
Francisco Los Angeles would be a
substance that that I would consider
living indeed these are all places on
the coast so I don't really have any
place I guess I'd go - what's an on
coastal place you know I could I could
go back to Burlington Vermont even
though that's on the lake and maybe they
would be screwed as well of course most
major cities are on some body of water
like I was thinking about Chicago or st.
Louis but I don't know it's kind of a
cop-out right they're not coastal but
st. Louis is on the Mississippi and you
know Chicago the Lake Michigan right
there so I don't know if it counts as
coastal but essentially the same thing
it has a shoreline of sorts although not
a not an ocean one yeah I don't know I
mean I I know that this is the totally
wrong point of view to take because I
think it gets people to not fix problems
but I do hope that we I'm not waiting
around for a solution to climate change
like I think we need to act now
but there are cities like Amsterdam that
exists below sea level
successfully and my hope is that at
least the protection of cities from sea
level rise will have some advancement in
terms of the technology that's available
before it becomes a problem in cities
like Boston in New York that could be
totally naive of me I mean maybe I'm
waiting around for something that is
just not going to happen but some of
these islands though I mean forget about
it
check out Key West while you can or you
know I think the Dead Sea is gonna dry
up by the year 2050 I'm also worried
about the Glacier National Park area I
guess apparently it's like the one place
you can go we're in the middle of the
summer and you know it's like 7080
degrees or whatever you'll have these
big mounds of snow and it's apparently
this beautiful view you can check out
but those glaciers are melting slowly
but surely and I want to check that out
before they're all gone yeah there's a
very famous large glacier area in my
home country of Argentina and I've never
visited but it is it's losing mass and
it's losing mass very quickly it's still
gigantic right still plenty to see but
that's that's a concern as well I at
some point I may have to stop being an
elite coastal progressive because there
might not be anything left I guess I
could still be on the coast it's just
the coast might be a hundred and fifty
miles inland from where it is right now
would you change your politics to you if
you moved no I would not no I would not
my politics would I would probably
become even more progressive because I
would be angry that climate change made
it so that we lost our coastal cities
yeah